[Music]
hi everyone its charlie a bunch of you
were messaging me last night to do a
video about this mysterious Marvel
teaser that they posted to their Twitter
account with a bunch of Roman numerals
in mysteriously leaked documents that
they were trying to release publicly and
make it look like someone was leaking
something most of you probably started
to figure out what's going on with this
just based on some of the redacted text
so I'll break it down it's all pretty
cool stuff but they're trying to tease a
whole bunch of big stuff that's getting
ready to happen so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Marvel Easter Egg videos it's only
gonna get crazier this summer with
spider-man far from home and their
marvel comic con panel and the Marvel
phase 4 schedule we're doing a new
giveaway for spider-man far from home
imax tickets all you have to do to enter
is leave a spider-man or Marvel comment
on the video I'll name a new winner at
the end of this so Marvel tweeted this
out late last night somebody actually
sent this to me because for some reason
it didn't pop up in my feed right away
it was super late right after midnight
everyone was going crazy because at
first glance the way that Twitter
generates its previews it really did
look like somebody accidentally messed
up at Marvel like wait a minute were
they supposed to post this because it
clearly says do not post but in the body
of the tweet it had the Roman numerals 2
4 5 6 & 9 at the top so somebody
actually wrote this and then pasted the
link into the tweet so very clearly they
wanted to release this information for
people to find understood that reference
and as you probably suspected there's
just a whole bunch of Easter eggs for
Wolverine Captain America the Weapon X
program the weapon Plus program is
really what it's called because there's
actually 16 different quote-unquote
weapons Wolverine is Weapon X that just
means the 10th version of the weapon
Plus program
don't worry I'll explain what this has
to do with the movies because we already
know that you Jackman isn't gonna turn
right around and be in a Marvel movie
right away during Marvel phase 4 but
they are starting to set some stuff up
so you kind of see what's going on in
these Easter eggs that they lay in these
heavily redacted documents go [ __ ]
yourself
when you click through the link it takes
you to the official Marvel web site with
a bunch of broken code but three very
clearly heavily redacted documents that
they want you to start reading with
enough clues that you can tell which of
the characters the documents are meant
to be about the first one reads research
memorandum weapon one and then you just
read date of birth 1918 Brooklyn New
York service us
Armie there's little tags on the sides
of the documents that read all
information contained herein is
unclassified date six 1719 which is next
week so it implies there's gonna be a
lot more of this stuff happening next
week too but then I'll just read through
some of this heavily redacted text here
just as significance US Army rejected 4f
heart trouble u.s. army general test
subject highly classified codename
Reinstein super soldier vitae raised
undisclosed mission a bomb exploded
Hydra along with friend presumed dead
North Atlantic sea preserved Avengers
lead shield the Winter Soldier
there was probably enough clues at the
beginning of this for you to pick up
that they're talking about Captain
America so Captain America is the first
weapon weapon one in the weapon Plus
program because Wolverine Weapon X and
all the other proto quote weapons that
people try to create over the years were
just their attempts to try and recreate
the super soldier program
so basically Wolverine was another
attempt to try and create another super
soldier in the vein of Captain America
with a lot of changes they were trying
to do the exact same thing with each
different version each new iteration
tries to introduce new wrinkles and new
types of powers like in this weapon one
document it reads codename Reinstein
Reinstein is the codename the dr.
Erskine used when he was in America
developing their super soldier program
that they used to create Captain America
the vitae rays were the thing that they
bombarded him with after they injected
him with all the serum but then
obviously the next teaser is research
memorandum Weapon X pretty much
everybody that's ever been to see at
least one Wolverine movie even if you
have read the comics probably knows what
Weapon X refers to it says date of birth
unknown because the Weapon X people
Stryker and the people that created
Wolverine did not know what his birthday
was but we actually do know what it was
he was born to the name James Howlett in
the late 1880s so he's not quite as
ancient as people think but he's still
really really old because he ages so
slowly that's just one of his natural
mutant powers before he entered the
Weapon X program then it reads first
Canadian parachute battalion CIA team X
because he just joined a whole bunch of
teams through the years as he became
part of the Weapon X program
significance member of multiple units
just referring to all the different wars
that he fought in mercenary mutation
manifested itself as a young boy killed
ran off with his childhood friend
talking about Sabretooth because they
both have the mutant ability to heal
Sabretooth is only a couple years older
than Wolverine the Canadian military in
World War one team X implanted false
memories they implanted him with false
memories during the Weapon X program
because they were trying to control him
and turn him into a weapon so they
didn't want him remembering where he
came from program experimenting
adamantium bones claws of adamantium the
healing factor the alias talking about
his Wolverine codename Professor Charles
Xavier the x-men mutants wiped his mind
force sent to assassinate betrayed so
those were all just references to his
life as Weapon X them trying to control
him and use him as a weapon of mass
destruction and him fighting against
that to try and get his memories back so
I'll explain how this is relevant to
what's going on during Marvel phase four
and Marvel phase five in the movies in a
second the third redacted document is a
bit of a deep cut it just reads research
memorandum Weapon 13 subject Charlie
cluster 7 that's phantom x from the
comics they're trying to tell you way
more information about this character I
think just because he's so much more
obscure than say someone like Wolverine
or Captain America the weird thing about
phantom X is that he's sort of half
machine half person because his mother
made it with a machine don't ask how
that happened but I don't think that
they have any plans to do him in the
movies anytime soon so you don't
necessarily need to know a whole lot
about what's going on with phantom X
this is really all just about the weapon
Plus program in the background that's
the more important thing in the stuff
that's going on with Wolverine the
reason why the tweet has the Roman
numerals 2 4 5 6 & 9 in it is just
because it sounds like they're gonna
reveal more about what's going on with
the nature of the weapon Plus program
and who these other people are they'll
become bigger characters in the future
the ones that we do know about because I
said that there's 16 total weapons in
the program our weapon 3 skinless man
weapons 7 is new keys from the daredevil
comics they also didn't during the
Jessica Jones Netflix show for a little
while Weapon 12 is called huntsmen it
has powers that are a little closer to
what's going on with phantom X's ability
to possess people with a hive mind
within 14 or the Stepford cuckoos
because
even though their DNA comes from Emma
Frost so she's technically their mother
they were created Emma Frost didn't give
birth to them like a normal person would
weapon 15 is called ultimatum he was
created to kill off Wolverine and the
other members of the weapon Plus program
but died in an explosion during the
attempt weapon 16 is called all God
which had absolutely bizarre powers of
belief making people believe in it if
they believed in religion it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense so don't worry
about that and then weapon H is just the
latest one in as Clayton Cortez who's
sort of a combo of Wolverines powers
hoaxes powers with an adamantium
skeleton bonded to him he's also a
character we're probably never going to
see in the movies maybe in an animated
series at some point because they're
doing that animated MODOK series during
Marvel phase four they're doing a little
bit crazier stuff because now that
Disney owns all the content from Fox
x-men Deadpool and Fantastic Four they
can do pretty much any crazy thing that
they want but Kevin Feige in the movie
people in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
keep things ways simpler way easier to
follow even though all the Marvel phase
for TV shows the Avengers spin-off stuff
that'll be connected to the movies
that's about as crazy as it's going to
get and there's only gonna be a couple
those per year but why does all this
weird weapon Plus program stuff matter
why are they trying to tease it so
clearly obviously Kevin Feige has said
that Hugh Jackman probably not going to
become Wolverine in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe right away
and it's gonna be a hot minute before
you actually see x-men characters
popping up in Marvel movies but what
they do though is they sort of seed that
stuff in years in advance and play
around with it in the comics just to get
people ready in fact because the Fox
Disney deal is done and now Kevin Feige
has access to all those x-men characters
they brought Jonathan Hickman on to do
their x-men comic books and he demanded
that they completely reboot everything
so right now it's the end of the x-men
in a lot of different ways the end of
the x-men at the Fox the end of those
movies as well as the end of the current
version of the x-men in all the comics
they're gonna completely reboot
everything just like Kevin Feige is
going to reboot all the x-men characters
when he starts to use them eventually so
how do you get people that love the
Wolverine character and love Marvel
movies ready for the idea that you're
going to recast one of the most iconic
character actors in comic book movies in
the last
20 years Hugh Jackman is Wolverine it
would be weird if they recast in
tomorrow people would a riot you slowly
start to introduce the idea of a brand
new version of all these characters but
then you also start teasing in the other
ideas that bind the character or at
least make him seem similar to the other
pre-existing characters you already have
like Captain America so what they'll
probably do is in a couple years when
they start to introduce the idea of
x-men in those concepts
Wolverine won't be one of the first
characters that they do they'll slowly
tease the comic book accurate story will
you learn about the existence of the
Weapon X program in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe some of the x-men characters
that they introduce will be brand new
young versions like they'll just get
their powers probably because of what
happened with fan OSes snap Tom Holland
recently in an interview for spider-man
far from home said the official party
line that they're being told to tell
everyone is that Thanos has snapped the
first time when he erased half of all
life tore a hole in the universe and
that's what opened up the multiverse to
all these threats that they're dealing
with in spider-man far from home I think
it's important to take that with a grain
of salt though but I do like the idea
that the cosmic energy that Rocket
Raccoon refers to energy released on a
cosmic scale that we've never seen
before and it happened a couple
different times between Thanos is snap
the Hulk snap in then Ironman snap all
within proximity to earth some of that
though used to explain how mutants start
to pop up in the MCU but that also
creates its own set of continuity
problems so don't worry too much about
it right now they're just trying to get
you used to the idea of all these x-men
concepts within the MCU before they
actually start to enact them and cast
these characters if I can finish in time
I might post another Deadpool video
later tonight because it was a funny
Dark Phoenix scene that they did during
that movie which sort of gave away the
ending to x-men Dark Phoenix a year
before the movie came out
congratulations to the giveaway winner
from my last big Marvel video Justin
Orion please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here to learn about the future of
Captain America during Marvel phase 4
because Chris Evans is coming back but
not the way you expect and click here
for my brand new spider-man far from
home trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome see you
you